i was sort of didn't know if i was ever
going to be a mom so
i'm excited well the day has finally
come for megan mccain
the 35 year old co-host of the view has
given birth to her first child
with hubby ben dominic megan announced
her pregnancy
in march nine months after experiencing
a devastating miscarriage i always
describe it as the inverse of losing my
dad because my dad was like
the ending of a beautiful long-lived
life
and i grieve that and the way i grieved
having a miscarriage and grieved my
daughter was
what could have been and grieving that
part so
it just hit me a lot harder than i
thought it would megan seemed happy
yet apprehensive while discussing her
baby news with her abc
co-hosts earlier this year amidst the
coronavirus pandemic
we're excited um a little surprised
uh you know it's bittersweet because
there's just a lot of people
in a lot of pain right now and i
obviously would prefer to be in studio
with all of you but
my doctors just i went to many
recommended against it
in may megan revealed in an instagram
post that she and dominic planned to
keep
details of her pregnancy journey private
writing in part quote
i believe children have a right to
privacy and hope you will all understand
as we navigate this
as much as possible going forward
without sacrificing our comfort
or safety megan explained that their
decision was due in part to negative
reactions
she got after posting about her father
senator john mccain's death
quote i learned a lot of hard lessons
about cruelty
that comes with being open and
vulnerable about my personal life
during my dad's cancer fight it used to
really bother me but i think you just
kind of after a certain amount of time
people say things so often
you just get desensitized we want to get
to know her better
so what was she like as a child
ungovernable
the late senator was diagnosed with
brain cancer in 2017.
the same year megan married her
conservative writer hubby
it doesn't get easier i wish i would
tell people it gets easier you just sort
of learn to cope with it better and
that's been the best
advice i've been given in june megan
showed dominic some social media love
thanking him for taking care of quote my
bloated
knocked up swollen pandemic navigating
self
i don't know what i would do these days
without such a strong
loving partner congratulations to the
new parents
you